When you ask people who the strongest straw
hats are, they will without a doubt tell you
Luffy and Zoro.
But Sanji???
There’s some intense debate about how strong
he actually is, so to end the Sanji hate once
and for all, let’s give him a simply broken
devil fruit to take him into the top-tier
of fighters in the story.
But that just leaves one very important question…
Which devil fruit is perfect for Sanji??
And let’s start with one of the coolest
devil fruits in the story, the Ice fruit.
And to explain why these chilly powers are
simply one of the best devil fruits for Sanji,
we have to break down exactly what makes our
curly-eyebrow chef so special.
For example, one of Sanji’s main passions
is cooking, so his perfect devil fruit would
definitely need to somehow contribute to his
cooking skills.
And the Ice devil fruit would absolutely help
Sanji as a chef because what cook doesn’t
need a way to keep their food cold?
He’s basically his own refrigerator.
On top of that, being able to freeze temperatures
has a ton of applications as a chef and you
can make special dishes by being able to instantly
freeze food.
What’s even more special though is that
this is one of the only fruits that can literally
create water, so the Straw Hats would simply
never run out of water with Sanji around.
So all around, pretty strong in the cooking
category.
Besides that though, we have to consider how
the devil fruit would improve his no-hands
fighting style.
Of course, the Sanji we know post-Wano already
has a super strong body and incredible strength,
but the Ice fruit would give him huge boosts
in defense and attack power earlier in the
story which could make him nearly unstoppable
in basically every one of his main fights.
Plus, the Ice fruit would easily enhance Sanji’s
kicking-based combat.
He could just make his legs super cold which
could freeze anyone he touches.
He could also add icy blades to his kicks
or even combine his natural fire powers with
these new ice abilities to be the ultimate
hot and cold fighter.
Plus he could shoot out ice projectiles and
even freeze water so the straw hats never
have to worry about drowning ever again.
Plus I’m sure he could tag team with Nami
to create some INSANE weather based attacks
by creating cold air for Nami to manipulate.
So at this point, you might be thinking THIS
IS the perfect fruit for Sanji, but we’ve
got many more that might be even better for
the Straw Hat’s chef, including the one
he dreamed about as a child.
This is of course the Suke Suke no mi, otherwise
known as the Invisibility fruit.
And for many people, this is the first power
they think about when it comes to giving Snaji
a fruit.
That’s because during the Thriller Bark
arc, we learned Sanji wanted to eat this fruit
ever since he was a kid because of, well,
some rather perverted reasons.
And if that was all Sanji used this fruit
for then honestly he probably wouldn’t live
very long with the straw hats because I’m
sure Nami would straight up kill him for peeking
in on her showers.
But let’s assume he could control himself
when it came to the ladies and seriously evaluate
this fruit for Sanji.
First off, the invisibility power is obviously
very useful in combat as he could hide from
most opponents.
In fact, he already had an invisibility power
up in Wano with his family’s technology,
but he chose to destroy his invisible suit.
Not that it mattered though because at this
point Sanji moves so fast he is basically
already invisible.
So that power would again just be a huge buff
for early story Sanji.
Besides that though this fruit wouldn’t
be all that useful for Sanji since it doesn’t
make him any stronger.
It also doesn’t help with his cooking much
except for maybe keeping his dishes a surprise.
So overall I don’t think this fruit is all
that great as a serious option for Sanji.
But this next fruit might actually be the
BEST FRUIT for chef Sanji.
Because we all know a knife is a chef’s
best friend.
So of course any chef would simply love to
get the Dice fruit, which allows the user
to turn any part of their body into a blade.
Which is just perfect for Sanji since he is
constantly slicing and dicing food in the
kitchen.
But beyond knives, he could turn himself into
so many different kinds of blades that are
useful in the kitchen, such as a spinning
blade to use as a blender or a rough blade
to act as a grater.
So clearly this fruit has endless uses in
the kitchen.
Beyond that though it also perfectly fits
with Sanji’s fighting style because he can
just turn his entire leg into a blade and
use that to attack his opponents.
Which would make him even more deadly than
he already is.
In particular, this fruit would have helped
Sanji A TON during his brief clash with Doflamingo
because if we assume by this point Sanji is
pretty good with his fruit and has decent
levels of haki, then there is literally no
better power to fight Doflamingo’s strings
than a bunch of blades.
So who knows, there might not even have been
a Dressrosa arc if Sanji had this fruit.
However, I have to admit it would be a bit
weird to see Sanji using blades since that
has always been Zoro’s thing.
Plus can you just imagine Sanji doing this
to his captain with a blade-leg.
Yikes.
That would be bye bye Luffy.
Although, I guess Sanji and Zoro could take
their rivalry to the next level by dueling
with their blades.
If we’re being honest though Sanji would
need a ton of practice to learn how to use
this fruit, which he actually wouldn’t need
if he ate this next fruit.
And before you laugh, just know that this
is my personal favorite fruit for Sanji, which
is the Big Horned Sheep devil fruit.
And while this fruit is currently not in the
story, the inspiration for this power comes
from the chapter 651 color spread where we
see the entire crew as animals.
And man, I just think this is so hilarious
to look at, but if you think about it, being
a Big Horned Sheep could actually be a huge
fighting boot for Sanji.
Because if you didn’t know these animals
are known for their incredible jumping and
balance which allows them to climb entire
cliffs by jumping up to twenty feet and landing
on tiny ledges.
Which means that for Sanji, who attacks mostly
with jumps and kicks, adding this natural
boost to his leg strength would make him even
more powerful than he already is.
Of course, this is also a Zoan fruit so Sanji
would also get natural boosts in all of his
physical stats like strength, speed, endurance,
and recovery.
Plus he gets the hybrid and full zoan forms,
which surprisingly might change his fighting
style quite a bit.
I mean, his rule is to never fight with his
hands, but if he has these massive horns on
his head, he would have to use them, right???
However, the one downside to this fruit is
that it doesn’t have any real applications
for Sanji as a chef.
So while it would be AWESOME, it probably
isn’t the BEST FRUIT for Sanji as a cook.
Which is the exact opposite of this next fruit,
which is the Cook Cook fruit that we were
introduced to during the Whole Cake Island
arc.
In case you don’t remember, this fruit allows
you to basically turn anything into food.
For example, this guy turned this log into
slices of meat and he later turned Big Mom’s
entire castle into a giant sponge cake.
So of course we have to discuss this fruit
because it seems absolutely perfect for a
chef like Sanji, right???
Well, I’m here to tell you that no, this
fruit would DESTROY the Sanji we know and
love.
For one, this is basically like a cheat code
for a chef since you really don’t even need
to cook to make food.
And for someone like Sanji who takes A TON
of pride in his cooking, he would likely feel
like he’d rather cook something incredible
on his own rather than just instantly making
food with his devil fruit.
Or if he ate this fruit as a kid and relied
on it for his cooking, he might have actually
never gotten to be the incredible chef that
he is today.
Plus, we aren’t even entirely sure how good
the food made by this fruit tastes.
Big Mom certainly didn’t like the taste
of the cake made from the fruit, so it’s
possible that the food doesn’t taste good
at all.
Although to be fair the quality of the food
probably depends on the skill of the user
and the situation, so food made in an emergency
probably wouldn’t be as good as something
made with time and preparation.
To be fair though, this is literally the perfect
fruit to have if you run out of food like
the crew did while sailing to Whole Cake Island.
However, I have serious doubts about Sanji
using this fruit in combat.
The only way I see Sanji using this fruit
in a fight is to turn other people’s weapons
into food.
For example, if he was fighting a swordsman,
Sanji could probably turn his opponent’s
sword into food.
That would seriously weaken his opponent,
but if we’re being honest it’s a pretty
weak combat ability compared to the other
powers we’ve already mentioned and the ones
coming up next.
Because even though the Cook fruit was not
a great fit for Sanji, there is a food-based
devil fruit that is a WAY BETTER fit.
That is the Mochi devil fruit, which would
be absolutely PERFECT if we had to pick a
food-based devil fruit.
That’s because this so called Special Paramecia
devil fruit has nearly all of the benefits
of a Logia fruit with the added benefit being
that the substance Sanji could turn into is
also edible.
So it’s great for combat and in the kitchen.
Let’s break it down.
Of course with mochi, Sanji could make an
endless supply of mochi-based treats, so in
theory the crew would never go hungry, which
is a major bonus for this fruit.
However, since Sanji can turn his body into
mochi AND produce the sticky-sweet substance
he gets a major boost in all of his combat
moves.
For example, as we saw when Big Mom’s strongest
son, Katakuri, used this devil fruit, Sanji
would be able to create mochi projectiles
and take out opponents from far away.
He could also enhance his kicks with mochi
by making his legs extra strong or even extending
their reach.
So yeah, this is an optimal fruit if we are
combining his role as a chef and a fighter.
However, even the mochi fruit simply CANNOT
COMPARE to the incredible power of the Pika
Pika no mi, also known as the light devil
fruit.
And man, this fruit regularly ranks near the
top strongest devil lists.
And for good reason.
Since this fruit is a Logia, Sanji would get
the obvious benefits of being able to turn
into light and shoot out light lasers.
And there is almost no better fruit to enhance
Sanji’s fighting style than by making him
faster.
We’ve already seen just how devastatingly
fast Sanji is during the Wano arc, but this
fruit would take him to a whole other level.
On top of just making him faster, Sanji would
also be able to shoot laser light beams, although
as with many of these fruits, it is questionable
if Sanji would ever use a ranged attack like
this.
We have actually seen him pull out a gun twice
in the story, but he’s never fired a bullet.
So would he shoot out light bullets with his
devil fruit?
It’s debatable, for sure, but as long as
he’s not using his hands I feel like Sanji
would do it.
So without a doubt, this fruit is a monster
for combat.
But how about in the kitchen?
Well, in order to effectively use light for
cooking, Sanji would need incredible control
of this power.
But if he could manage that, he could use
his light to heat up and cook food, since
light heats up objects as it passes through
them.
So much like the Ice devil fruit, this could
lead to some fancy new cooking techniques
that I’m sure Sanji would absolutely love
to test out.
But there’s one thing the light fruit wouldn’t
do for Sanji, and that is get rid of his number
one weakness.
Of course, I’m talking about the fact that
Sanji refuses to fight women, which has cost
him badly on more than once in the story.
However, to counter this exact weakness, there
are actually TWO fruits that would help Sanji
never have to fight a woman ever again.
I’m talking about this guy’s Hormone fruit
which can inject someone with enough hormones
to make them switch genders.
So that’s one option, and the other one
involves a brief manga spoiler here, but we
also have this guy’s Sick-Sick fruit, which
can infect people with a gender-swapping disease.
Both of these would allow Sanji to change
women into men so that he would have no problem
fighting them.
Which basically takes away his biggest weakness
as a fighter.
Although knowing Sanji, he would probably
never want to change a woman into a man, so
maybe these aren’t so great for him after
all.
So even with all of these incredible fruits,
I still wonder if we could somehow craft the
perfect devil fruit for Sanji that would put
him on the same level as Luffy and Zoro.
And since those two are both essentially gods
- Luffy is a Sun God, and Zoro has his Ashura
demon power - I figured, why not try to give
Sanji some mythical god powers as well.
So after doing some research, I found that
there is a Shinto deity called Ukemochi who
is the god of food.
Which just sounds perfect for Sanji because
Ukemochi is said to be able to create any
kind of food or even help crops to grow better.
That is obviously a plus in the chef category,
since Sanji could produce any ingredient he
could imagine to create some truly out of
this world recipes.
Seriously, Sanji would be in heaven, especially
since his dream of finding the All Blue specifically
mentions cooking with some special fish you
can’t find anywhere else in the world.
So yeah, this fruit is perfect for Sanji the
chef.
Fighting is another matter though, because
at first it doesn’t seem like this fruit
would have any real effect on his fighting.
And you might think that with his endless
supply of ingredients, Sanji could whip up
some deadly dishes to poison his opponents,
but I truly don’t think that Sanji would
EVER want to make food that would hurt someone.
So let’s flip this around and imagine that
with enough practice, Sanji could make food
that actually boosts his own strength, endurance,
recovery, or some other characteristic.
So I’m just imagining him getting ready
to fight by taking a bite of a special strength
boosting meal or something.
Which would be perfect to share with the entire
crew.
Although I don’t really know if he would
share it with Zoro.
This fruit might even be enough to settle
their age-old rivalry once and for all.
However, that is only considering Zoro at
his current strength, but it would be a completely
different story if Zoro had his own devil
fruit to compete with Sanji’s.
And if you want to see which fruit is the
PERFECT ONE for our green-haired swordsman,
you can watch this video right here.
Shanks for watching, and I’ll see you in
the next one.